hayden so good to see you man how are
you hey there how are you doing good to
see you too
i'm doing great listen i was talking to
ewing just last week and he told me
the day that you came on set
there were like a hundred more people
than usual
out there just to see you and he didn't
really quite understand what was going
on first and then you realize all right
darth vader's coming
and everybody here
you know kind of grew up on the movies
and are big fans of what you guys did
back then
you know what does it mean to you to be
able to have that
moment that sort of sensation
yeah i mean such a a special uh
reception i got on set
um what was really neat about it is that
there were a lot of star wars fans uh
that were part of our crew
um and i think they had probably the the
same reaction when they saw ewan for the
first time as obi-wan and
um and then when i got to step out as
darth vader
that was that was a another big moment i
guess
what about um
getting out there again for the first
time gave you butterflies the most like
what made you go
okay like that you had to pump yourself
up to get out there for
yeah i mean you know just just just
getting to play this character again uh
such a big deal for me you know this is
a role that that
uh you know i care a lot about means a
lot to me and
getting the opportunity to come back was
was something that that uh
you know was was really special um
you know every every day on set was was
a very sort of special occasion
was there a time in your life where you
just were like
there's no
there's no
story no opportunity no way that i can
imagine
coming back to this
i mean you know when we finished doing
the prequels i certainly had no concept
that we would be coming back and
uh and doing more with these characters
um
you know i i guess sort of as time went
on and and
and the storytelling in star wars
continued to sort of grow and expand
uh
the idea was maybe sort of percolating
somewhere in the back of my head
um but but no i mean when i finally got
the phone call uh it was it was a very
welcome surprise
there are
in like novelizations and comic books
and other side stories you know stories
where darth vader is the lead where the
comic book has his name right there in
the title that's his uh is there
are you open to the idea of doing a
series where you as anakin darth vader
are the lead of a new
uh
star wars franchise version of the story
yeah i mean
you know absolutely i think
this is a a character that sort of
um
resonates in our culture in a very kind
of profound way
and there's certainly more there to
explore you know
like you said there are there are you
know so many other stories that have
been told in these other mediums
um
and and
i would love to get to continue my
journey with him
right on man i'm so excited i know
you've probably heard this from press
like all week all month for the last
half a year or whatever but we're so
excited it's just days away so
thank you man i'm excited too i hope you
enjoy it
yeah right on thank you so much for your
time all right good to see you